في وقت سابق نشر رئيس فاجنر مقطعا مصورا
على حسابه في تيليجرام ومن ورائه جثث يقول
انها لافراد من قواته سقطوا في معارك
باخموت بسبب نقص ذخيره وهاجم بريكوتين
بشكل مباشر وزيره الدفاع
وقائد الاركان فاليري جيراسيموف مستخدما
سببا مباشرا بحقهما لعدم امداد قوته
بالذخيره المطلوبه
اين الذخيره اللعينه انظر اليهم لدينا نقص
بنسبه 70% في الذخيره اذا اعطيتنا الكميه
العاديه منها فسيقل عدد قتلانه خمس مرات
لقد اتوا الى هنا كمتطوعين انهم يموتون
حتى تبقى في منصيبيكما
هذا وافاد الجيش الاوكراني ان قواته صدت
نحو 60 هجوما روسيا في اتجاهات بخموت
ومارينكا ولمان شرقي البلاد وقال الجيش ان
معارك عنيفه تجري في بخموت ومارينكا وان
القوات الروسيه تنفذت عمليات هجوميه وصفها
بالفاشله على عدد من المحاور في باخمت
خصوصا منطقتي ماركوف وبهداني